はいみなさんお待たせいたしましたはずみ社長の質問こんな10月版でございます
今回ですね今までと違いました youtube の方のコメントスイッたあの方の
譜面と2つの質問リクエストいただいておりますなのでへと合計するとものすごい数の
そのね質問やリクエストをいただいたことはまず感謝申し上げますありがとうござい
ます
youtube 版と
を twitter 版の動画を2つ作ろうと思っておりますでとりあえず今回は
youtube 版ですねちなみに何なんですかって質問には今回
答えておりは戦で愛子五飛呼ばれないんでしょとか言ってるとこんなやり取りしてる
もしかしてだけどまぁ作まーさーかーのまさか
採用です
今度から質問しようね地下鉄ですか僕は地下鉄じゃないですね
誰をいくつですか僕普通ではのいいですね
彼人二波で逆さのプリンカレーたなか唯晴れ晴れ
カレーがんだって
ありがとうございます dare you do
テンション max べく覚めしてください air
pa
パパッ
真似してるのうるさいすみませんした最近うちゅうじんが家によく遊びに行くんですよ
な方が楽しんでもらえないんですけどどうしたらいいですが
でもじゃがりこあげるすごい喜んでくれるんですよかわいいでしょじゃあ自分の顔投げ
てください
バーン井戸山や入っ
うんっ
4位
お前のせいだかもうダメだこんなにコメントがもう無理だ
でもこれがいう中大丈夫ですあのコメント採用されない人もちゃんと動くコメントを見
てますから安心してください住所教えてください
静岡け
靴
訓練はいえの通称教えてください何でもそんな7だけのうち沿い
ちゃんってくださいもやしだから例えば立てれば漫画エロ
これどうすれば人を行うでどうしても足が踏み出せない動作で行けるようになるとこの
僕も不等号ってわけじゃないんですけども実は夏休み前から学校に出ませんでしたあ
サボってたわけじゃないよ
不登校でもないですよもう事業が足りてる爺様が一個もなかったんで学校行ってなかっ
たんですけども学校にも行ってないし夏休みは学校に行かなかったんで久しぶりに学校
に行くのがすごい怖かったです3 f
あってす登校になっているかもしれないんですけども今後夏休み明けに社食にが後行っ
た時はもう変な汗めっちゃかきながら言ってたんですっげー来づらい共通がわかるん
ですけど
ちゃえば何とかなると思いますもういいや吹くまま
味は目 neo 2したをできる限り口の中で詰めてくださいまあ初めはビビってでき
ないだろうがこの俺をなめてもらっちゃ困る靴下なんても余裕で全部食べてやるもん
あー全力で生きてくださいああ
カーンをしていた
ああああああ
yeah
これでこんだけコメントきて大変やなぁコメントたくさんあって良いのは大変なんです
けどもみなさんのコメントはないと成り立たない動画でございます本当にコメントして
くださった皆さんありがとうございます冊を好きでチャンネル登録ボタン2回押し
ちゃったら会えを解除してんじゃねーか友達が理由もなく殴ってくるどうしたらいい
始めただが暴力者をちゃんだいたい言ってた話に言ったほうがいいよ
それが願いして
対してなんで数え買えないからって頭に鰹節載せてるんですかバル鰹節じゃねえは
カツオ節やね
俺は魔界からやってきたわけだというず別定なはじめとする
さあ僕のどこがこれから4つのほうが勝つに神の代表曲流れるさ勝負だはじめ
勝負を既に始まっているいい精神科の病院教えましたよ始めよう福田一のどこで買っ
てるの
いつも適当
ネットでパパって買う時もあるし人が多いの番号を見せてからドーリーかけなんで電気
で霧の服屋さんに飛び込んでパパって定義さんと話しながら買ったりしますブランドと
かあんま興味ないんだよなぁ着たいものを切ります活動をしたりしてください
メーラーこの子の動画つまんないよはじめ
me
えっ何て言った鞍上日の時欲しくもないものをもらった反応ない
タージのでねーピットに
のすぐにないまあその2州で看板ありがとうございますって人に頑張ります本気で壁に
ストライクショットしてください
パンパースを短パンしてくださいこれのためにパンパースを買った俺
おしっこをらっしゃるでしょ村してませんごめん俺やお前開封しするなよね管その動画
で風邪ひいて畑なくマットですねくださいマギーの時に使いソースプロジェクトが
ちゃんと効い中核事業所にもチャンネル登録
どんな場所なのかも知れません全部兄の形見とらっしゃいっになりますんをっに刑務所
や救急で精神科の放ってまいります数買おうとしていい
そして鼻を大きくしていいそして目は白身にしてねええええ
キモいんだよ大網時の建白なんで出来る時で14に逆らってサイヤ人になってください
いつも書いてるから弱火髪の毛が長く人が痛むから松ケ岳ないですよねいじめは
なくなると思いますか
いじめが謎を受けるだけ性格の違いとか能力も強いとが原因で起きること
ありますねいじめっていうのは我々が個性とか能力の差がある可能ということだって
欲しい俺たちがみんな同じ人間同じ性格同じ能力だったら一番かけると思いますみんな
がみんな違うから市場プチュッに皆同じ能力同じちっにょ示していいもの買って
でもそうではないんだよね一面がなくなることはないと思うけどもいじめがなくなる
ように努力することが大切だと僕は思います
組合てユニークだとでしょうか質問コーナー youtube バージョン本当に
たくさんのコメのみなさんありがとうございました理解に同じ痩せで続くとちょっと姉
なんで来週 twitter の質問このやろうと思いますホント皆さんたくさんの
試聴ありがとうございました
じゃあ何
me
ん
うん